they're fighting
on several fronts in india fighting to
save lives
but also fighting to tell it as it is
and those at this hospital in lucknow
are now facing police charges for doing
just that
every covered patient who arrives here
desperately needs oxygen
but those who sounded the alarm about
oxygen shortages at this hospital
are now being charged under the national
security act
and face being arrested at any moment
[Music]
the head of this small hospital says
four of his patients died in one day
when oxygen ran out
he showed me the messages he put out
desperately asking for help
when he got no response he put out a
notice telling relatives they should
take the patients elsewhere
a number of them did but others had no
choice
the hospital head took us to see his
small oxygen store
it's again at dangerously low levels the
state's high court has said
not supplying oxygen to hospitals is a
criminal act
no less than genocide
but the oxygen ran out by nine o'clock
that morning
the relatives of those who died say
that's what killed
them
if the oxygen had been there my aunt and
cousin would not have died he told us
as we traveled through uttar pradesh
with its huge population
of 200 million we found many ignoring
covert warnings
this is meant to be locked down still
bustling with people
and few masks
in the shadow of india's most famous
monument they appeared
oblivious to the virus
doctors we've spoken to say the mutation
which has spread to other countries
including britain
is a far more aggressive infectious
variant
and affecting far younger people it
seems that the virus is more lethal this
time
it seems so because the number of deaths
have been a little higher than what was
what we saw last time also what we are
observing is
last year it took some time for the
patient to deteriorate
but with this virus the infectivity or
the
aggressiveness of the virus is so high
that it hardly takes a day
for the patient otherwise fine to
desaturate and
get compromised
there's a fear about contradicting the
official numbers
but this crematorium in agra has run out
of wood
and is now using cow dung for its
funeral pies
nearly two-thirds of indians live in
remote
rural areas unable to get any help for
covid
with many dying at home and untested
the workers have no protective outfits
against the virus
whilst telling us they've never been so
busy but they're reluctant to give exact
figures
why don't you just tell them the young
boy behind him says
he gets a furious response
in these areas of such deprivation where
religious sadhus are often the only
people recognising the dead
we may never know the real toll of the
pandemic in india
alex crawford sky news in uttar pradesh